you've taught us a lot Carlos you've
shown us what true friendship looks like
and you also proved that being the son
of a villain doesn't make you evil you
showed us the importance of asking out
our crushes no matter how nervous it
makes us feel drink would you be my date
you're always there for your friends and
you're pretty much the best dog owner in
the world no matter what you'll be in
our hearts forever Cameron Boyce was
taken way too soon but he will forever
live on as Carlos from descendants keep
watching for 10 of Carlos news best
moments from The Descendants franchise
the carrot cake Carlos from The
Descendants films may have been one of
the cool kids on the aisle but he was
just another awkward teen with a crush
at auradon prep he really had a thing
for Jane but he was so shy whenever he
was around her it didn't help that Jane
was really shy too
we can't forget the time he tried to ask
her out but totally freaked out instead
carrot cake real smooth Carlos and even
that wasn't a great conversation starter
because Jane had the pumpkin pie awkward
say hi to the missus
Oh Carlos even when he's getting into
trouble he can't help but be a good guy
in the first movie he and the other vks
break into the museum when the security
phone rings Carlos answers it he uses
his mad computer skills to help whoever
is on the other end answer a question
and he's so friendly about it poor
Carlos mal and Jay definitely loved
being villains but it was never really
Carlos his idea of a good time in
descendants to mal wants to know if
Carlos misses being bad
don't you ever miss screaming of people
and just making them run away from you
Carlos dropped a truth bomb on mal he
says that the person who screamed was
his mother and she was usually screaming
at him so he does not miss his VK life
mal definitely needed a reality check
and Carlos was there to give her one a
terrible liar Carlos is a lot of things
but a good liar isn't one of them he's
not always quick on his feet when he
needs to create an excuse in descendants
to he's trying to cover for Edie who has
returned to the Isle of the Lost
she went camping Doug is immediately
suspicious because Evie is a total diva
she would never sleep outside but Carlos
tries to play it off no one is buying
that excuse Carlos rotten to the core
who can forget the first time we saw
Carlos's killer dance moves he revealed
his awesome dancing skills in the song
rotten to the core he did flips through
the orphanage and trashed the market and
he looked so cool doing it plus his
voice sounded amazing when he sang the
bridge we were seriously impressed with
his moves and his voice we're pretty
sure that was the moment that we started
loving Carlos and of course we know that
Carlos is the opposite of rotten we're
family
we all need a friend who can tell us the
hard stuff and Carlos is definitely that
friend he isn't afraid to call out his
BFFs when they aren't being good friends
he reminds them that they're all family
and they've been through a lot together
a lot together we could all use a Carlos
in our lives my printer my crown and
what's gonna happen next we'll have
girls playing turning guys can we all
agree that chad charming is ridiculous
he kept breaking into Carlos's room into
Sundance - Carlos used his awesome
computer skills to take his 3d printer
to the next level and Chad was so
jealous it's so funny when he catches
Chad in his room on the phone with
Audrey she got a flat tire and sure
and she wants me to go fix it Chad had
just made himself a crown with the
printer carlos plays it cool and demands
chad to give him the crown after all it
is his printer run carlos run Cruella de
Vil fed her son a lot of lies about dogs
mom said they're rabid pack animals who
eat boys who move but Carlos had never
actually met a dog so endued runs on to
the tourney field he is freaked he takes
off running and just doesn't stop it was
totally hilarious it's definitely one of
Carlos's funniest moments of all of the
movies the look on Ben's face when
Carlos just keeps running is priceless
Carlos and Jane it may have taken him a
while to get the courage but Carlos
finally asks Jane out and it's the
sweetest moment ever he asks her to
cotillion and then he wants to know if
they can be more than friends would you
consider being more than friends and
Jane is so excited she says she's the
luckiest girl in the world and we agree
then she hugs Carlos it's just too sweet
he looks surprised but then he hugs her
back this moment gets us right in the
feels every time Carlos and dude if
there's any love story better than
Carlos and Jane its Carlos and dude
Carlos spends most of the movies totally
inseparable from dude the dog but
there's nothing better than the moment
he realizes dogs aren't evil it shows
him that his mom was wrong which is
important for his character growth and
for the first time he experiences
unconditional love dude is everything
that Carlos needed what is your favorite
Carlos moment let us know in the
comments thanks for watching don't
forget to give this video a thumbs up
and hit that big red subscribe button
[Music]